kyle is with us in florida hate Kyle
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
hey John how y'all doing today
great man how can we help yeah so um
here's my scenario I'm $40,000 in debt
and I just recently separated with my
wife and we're gonna be gone through the
process of divorce so I live in Florida
but I'm planning to move back home to be
all safe that rent amounts to start
tackling my baby step two I'm currently
waiting for my stimulus check to tackle
baby step one I have about a little over
four thousand dollars in credit card
debt and then my vehicle is thirty five
thousand and I'm about eight thousand
negative equity so my plan is to after I
pay down both my credit cards to pay as
close to my negative equity or to zero
as possible and then sell that vehicle
and buy a five to six thousand dollar
vehicle and then I used chase they have
a deferment plan for three months so I
want to start using that money to start
tackling my baby step two I just want to
know if I'm on the right path how long
have you been married
we've been together for going on 11
years but married for eight years what
happened she started having feelings for
somebody else and she she said she fell
out of love with me so I was willing to
try she was not willing to try to mend
the problems within our relationship I'm
sorry to hear that
so what are you 30 yeah yes and what do
you make what's your income so my
guaranteed income from the VA is a 630 a
month when I moved to Connecticut um I
will be trying to find as many jobs or a
job that pays me at least 20 200 a month
that up about 30
6,000 a year who do you owe the money to
on the car on the card VI teeth say it
again
chase IP yes okay what I first want you
to do is contact the chase because this
car is absolutely insanity in your
situation if your wife was making a
hundred thousand dollars a year maybe it
was less insane but with your current
income a thirty five thousand our car is
off the chain and crazy so I would
contact chase about the idea of signing
a note for the difference letting them
let you sign a note for the $8,000
negative equity and get it sold now
because I'd rather you eight thousand
and thirty five thousand years ago and
will that affect her would that affect
her credit I don't want to affect
anyone's credit if they do that deal you
know yeah it's no one's credit is
affected if they do that deal or if you
can borrow the eight thousand anywhere
even on a credit card it would be better
than having a thirty five thousand
dollar debt we're reducing your debt
thirty five to eight and that gets you
there so what's the nature of your
disability from the military just knees
back ass reflux headache stuff like that
thank you for your service I'm sorry you
were hurt
all right yeah that that's the the
financial part of it is to try to get
rid of this car because it's the glaring
thing sticking up in your overall
picture if you didn't have that car
payment you would have a lot of relief
agreed yes yes I would okay now I have a
question about that uh that strategy it
will be I don't have any money saved so
I can't go out and buy another vehicle
um what should i do so I wait to save
that six thousand dollars for that
vehicle I don't know the change six
thousand our vehicle you need a thousand
dollar vehicle for right now you know
hoop do you around to get just something
to get around you don't need a fancy
right now we're trying to get out of
debt and you don't have a ton of income
you don't hardly have any income right
this second and so you're moving back in
with mom and dad right yeah at 30 years
old after an eight-year marriage okay
that's gonna be tough
agreed yes very
yeah like awkward and weird a little bit
yeah okay so my point of that is not to
say that you shouldn't do it I'm okay
with it being a safety net you know
while you go through a hard time but I
want you to immediately start working on
your exit strategy too because you're
gonna want to be out soon
John what are your thoughts yeah that
can I be honest with you for a second
Kyle yeah you sound like a broke and
here's what I wanna tell you a little
bit right now yeah I want to make sure
that you honor the transition that's
happening and you're clearly a stud
you've done military service you've
sacrificed yourself for bigger things in
us that I don't want you to blow over a
divorce I don't want you to blow over
what a big deal it is to move home with
your parents and I think a lot of times
we start to start trying to solve
problems with math problems and right
now you've got a heart problem too so I
want you to hear me say dude you're
worth being well and you're worth being
okay and I'm I have a hundred percent
confidence that you're going to work
around the other side of this Dave's
right you got to sit down with your mom
and your dad and make a plan for what
moving homes gonna look like what their
rules are gonna look like and then your
plan to leave their home and you're
worth more than $36,000 a year by the
way - you're worth more than a couple of
part-time jobs my friend okay so I'm
going to send you a copy of Christine
Coleman's book the proximity principle
to help with the career side of things
that's Ken's specialty and he'll walk
with you through this brother listen if
your hearts broken that would make you
what's called a normal human being and
that's what John and I are saying we're
acknowledging that with you and we can
hear the pain in your voice - I don't
blame you for hurting it wouldn't you
would be weird you'd be a psychopath if
you weren't hurting in this situation
you've got a lot of stuff going on here
what you're trying to execute all the
all the tactical decisions which is good
but Johnson don't drive by the emotions
while you're doing that get both done
good question man when you got home
we're with you brother